бывает ли такое что садится батарейка
потому что у вас очень плотный график
дисциплина я вижу насколько все описано
бывает такое что вот не хочется вставать
не подойти
вы знаете наверное нет потому что
являюсь автором методики к ним
планирование и там есть раздел
называется power менеджмент управление
временем вообще считаю что многие люди
вообще большинство неправильно считают
что основной ресурс человека до время на
самом деле пока вы живы время у вас есть
всегда когда вы мертвой у вас нет
времени а когда вы живы если у вас есть
время то у вас есть 24 часа в сутках 7
двигатель и 365 дней в году как у любого
человека но проблема в том что у нас
может быть время есть но энергия
зачастую у молодых людей многих и
особенно в современном мире батарейка
заканчивается хотя время у них лист хотя
они планируют умеет все и в этом плане
вот моя методика power management
управление энергией
она спасает потому что я когда
соблюдаете все правила
а я уже и соблюдаю на автопилоте я
никогда не довожу уровень батарейки там
вижу 7 процента ну а там есть разные
цари когда ты занимаешься любимым делом
энергии подписывать подпитывающие когда
ты общаешься с хорошими людьми энергия
приходит и там много таких методик потом
хотя мой график вроде смотрится очень
плотным но он очень правильно чередуется
через
очень плотная работа потом полный
релаксация отдых очень плотно работа
смена занятий много прилично ну вот
отсюда я хотел спросить у вас три дочери
вас семья три дочери кстати меня тоже
три дочери классных большая часть баланс
личного и
работы work on line вы много проводить
времени со своими детьми и если да то на
какие темы
какая ваша роль в их развитии да я бы
знаете это процесс и двухсторонние
поэтому можно сказать так один вариант
одно когда ты хочешь проводить больше
времени с детьми другой вопрос когда
дети хотят хотят ли они с тобой больше
правами поэтому у меня к сожалению
сейчас дочки
старше работает bloomberg от дани бухты
она там сети она покрывает францию на
французском языке клиентов ja2
дочь и младшие они 12 лет исполнилось 13
пошел и и они в таком возрасте когда
хотят свою территорию больше отправился
больше про java se у них сейчас подруги
и там и когда мы хотим с ними вместе
больше времени провели проводить то ты
всегда получается потому что родители
хотят они даже просто поцеловать уже
лично но эти получается так что вот ваша
методология power менеджментом связали
управления или энергии ресурсами
временем это все помогает поддержать
балансе